you
[Music]
the talk is a causal data science has
anyone read my blog on medium if I the
same title a couple couple folks okay
cool so it's some of the content might
be familiar from that if not you can
actually go there for a little bit more
detail on a lot of these things so let's
go ahead and and get started so I'll
kind of go through what is causal
inference and white why you should care
about it so this is something that you
can do kind of in the setting of data
analytics you can also apply it as Tony
pointed out in his talk to machine
learning problems in a way that corrects
biases that are inherent in an observed
data observed data sets so that is non
experimental data sets so then I'll run
through a little bit on how you do it
with kind of a quick motivating example
which hopefully brings out some
important aspects of doing causal
inference and then say given the upfront
kind of cost of changing your analytics
workflow of putting in the time
investment to learn some fairly
theoretical concepts to build up the
skills to do causal inference is it
actually worth doing that and when can
you justify that extra cost cool who
here's done causal inference before in
some in some respects cool ok small
handful of people so hopefully a lot of
this is new and worthwhile so we'll kind
of get get right into it so what do I
mean by causal inference let's kind of
start there so really we're thinking of
some some state so some some potential
action you might take and the effect of
that action on some outcome so that
could be the effect of exercise on a
person's life expectancy as measured in
years the effect of educational
attainment on lifetime earnings this is
something you might study in a more
social science setting the effect of a
change in a product to some engagement
metric so this is something that would
be very common in in data science or
data analytics the effect of a policy
action on stock markets so this this
type of thing might be more common in
finance so all of these are examples of
causal inference what they all have in
common is there's some notion of a
causal state so that's the the variable
that is
defining your action so this could be
something like a binary variable if
you're talking about a policy action
it's we we don't do it so D is equal to
zero D being the causal state or we do
do it so if d is equal to one or we're
true if you like that for the boolean so
then once you have once you've got a
causal state there's some outcome you
care about so this this will be some set
of metrics potentially but we'll kind of
keep the focus narrow as one single
metric and you can talk about the causal
effect of the causal state on any any
collection of metrics if you like but
each of those is a separate inference
problem for the purposes of this
discussion so then there's some other
set of variables you might care about so
these are Co variants they might reduce
the noise in your estimation or they
might have some more significant purpose
which we'll talk about in a little bit
and finally there's the causal effect so
what is actually the difference in the
outcome given the policy action so if I
implement some change to a product on my
website how much do I expect our
engagement metrics to increase so what
we mean there is what's the difference
between the outcome if I were to
implement the policy from the outcome if
I were not to implement the policy so
that's that difference and it's exactly
a difference so the subtract one from
the other is is something we'll talk
about as the causal effect cool so just
kind of to make this all more a little
bit more concrete I just listed a few of
these things and I actually put little
numbers and stuff so you can kind of see
that there so usually we'll set Z or
sorry D is the causal state the outcome
will usually be Y so that's the notation
for that the covariates will usually be
Z or s so these are some examples
suppose we're making a product change so
the control state for an a/b test is 0
the tests test state is D equals to 1
we're worried about several outcome
metrics on our website so the time
engaged on the website number of
engagements and the rate of people
re-engaging so these are each outcomes
we care about and then in each of these
cases there's a causal causal effect we
care about so the average improvement
and engagement time between the test
group and the control group or the
average improvement and engage
time or sorry number of engagements
between the test and control group or
whatever other metrics you care about so
we we use a B test as the example
because they're kind of the the gold
standard for doing causal inference but
we can ask the question backing up a
little bit why do we why do we need an
experiment why can't we just look at the
data that we already have which is how
people are interacting with our products
and and say what the effect of a change
in the product would be from that data
so that's a that's a question that's
worth asking because often we aren't
able to run an experiment so often we
just have observational data and this
this happens typically if the policy
change is irreversible for example like
you're changing the way you structure a
product or the way you sell the product
or if or if you don't control the system
that you're trying to assess the policy
effects of which is common in economic
Social Sciences and in other settings so
let's look at why we run an experiment
with a motivating example so d our
causal state is whether a person on a
website season advertisement Y is
whether they buy an Associated product
and Z is whether they're active on the
internet so there's circles drawn for
each of these variables and there are
arrows pointing from cause to effect in
each case so we expect that the ad has
an effect on whether you'll buy a
product we expect your online activity
has a in effect on whether you'll see
the advertisement it also has an effect
on whether you'll buy the product so
people who are more active online are
more likely to see ads people who are
more active online are more likely to
purchase products online so that's the
the basic setting so what happens in
this context so if we if we take more
active users we'll find both that
they're more likely to see the ads so
those users actually do see the ad more
often and they're also more likely to
purchase products and what we end up
with is those two variables we will be
correlated even if there's no effect of
seeing the ad on buying the products so
you can actually find that in settings
where the product will be completely
unrelated to the ad that somebody saw
but you'll still see a large ad effect
for for those unrelated products so
that's a clear example where you have
some spurious relationship between the
variables there's actually a common kind
of methodology and native advertising
where somebody will define their test
group is people who saw an advertisement
the control group is people who did not
see the advertisement and then when they
they run this sort of pseudo experiment
because they they are actually running
the ad on the site and they'll find
gigantic ad effects with something like
thousands of percent bias so we'll see
some examples like that cool so this
kind of leads us to the question why
should we care about these about these
biases so one one argument that you
might hear and I've heard this often is
well we don't really need to go into the
details and figure out how to deal with
this problem we expect that it's small
compared to the effects that we're
looking for or at least are measured
effect should be directional for the
true effect where directional is kind of
a vague and undefined term so let's look
at why exactly we should care about this
type of thing so there's this nice paper
that came out of Yahoo Research Oh a
good while back where they took
observational studies and compared them
with the results of experiments that
were run in the same setting so that's a
great way to to figure out okay what
would the bias be if we looked at an
observational study instead of an
experimental study so how wrong would we
get it is the kind of is the question
that they set out to answer so on the
x-axis is the the day of exposure to an
advertisement the y-axis is an outcome
metric that they care about and they
looked at these four different outcome
metrics so they were showing
advertisements to people for visiting
pages in the Yahoo network so they they
have the probability of a visit within
the new Yahoo Network a probability of a
visit to yahoo.com a probability of a
visit to Yahoo Mail and a probability of
or sorry and then just the number of
pages within the Yahoo network so if you
look at this it looks like on the day of
exposure there's this huge effect right
so there's this giant spike and you
you would say okay looking at this data
it looks like the ads are really
effective but notice there's this kind
of first clue that some things are going
wrong which is the zero point here the
day of exposure is has some ramped up
before it so that it looks like there's
this kind of a causal effect where
somebody is more likely to visit a page
within the Yahoo Network before actually
seeing the advertisement so so what
exactly is going on there that's weird
right so this is this problem of
activity bias so that at least is argued
by the the authors of this paper so what
the the issue here is is that you're
more likely to visit a page within the
Yahoo Network today if you visited the
oppo network yesterday and so there's
this correlation in time with your
online activity and so this activity of
bias is what you're seeing with these
spikes so what you actually have here is
the blue curve is a test group and the
red curve is the control group so this
is actually a comparison against a
randomized trial and so you can see
there's a spike in the control group as
well as the test group and it's again
that's due to this activity issue if you
look at the difference in probability to
visit on the day of the advertisement
you can see it's the difference between
these Peaks here and you can try to
follow it as it as it falls off
afterwards but you should see no
statistically significant difference
before before exposure to the
advertisement and so this study found no
statistically significant difference in
the outcome metrics due to exposure to
the ad even though there's this gigantic
bias for for what you would expect from
an observational study so if you were to
estimate the search lift just to put
this in numbers you would find over a
thousand percent improvement from this
from this advertisement just from the
observational study where the true
effect this is actually in adjacent
study slightly different one but same
same context was 5.4 percent so it's
taking the ratios of those two that's
two thousand percent bias
that was actually observed in a a real
advertising setting go any questions at
this point this is probably a good time
to to pause yeah okay cool so so the the
answer to why you should care about it
at so far is because the the biases
aren't small if well we'll get into a
little bit more detail on kind of the
tolerable limits of bias in just a
little bit so when in general does this
happen we looked at one particular
context where there is this common cause
between the causal state and the outcome
so we had people being active online
makes you more likely to see the
advertisement being active online that
makes you more likely to see other pages
in the Yahoo Network or to purchase a
product online so it's this common cause
kind of concept which is driving this
spurious association between the causal
state in the outcome so in general there
are lots of different things that could
be common causes of the causal stately
or the treatment and the outcome the
effect of the cause of State so you
could have in a web context - generally
there are attributes of the user that
might cause both so that user activity
it was an example that we looked at just
a second ago attributes of the context
so they could have heard maybe from
somewhere else that they should get
online today for some reason so that
could drive this kind of activity-based
confounding and then there's attributes
of the context that could also affect
both of these things so these are just a
few different categories that are that
are useful to think about in a web
context because it's kind of a nice way
to split up the world but you could come
up with other categories as well so what
I what I'm arguing here is that this is
actually a very general problem and it's
not just the feature of that specific
context we looked at a second ago a few
a few years ago I was seeing tons of
blog articles that looked something like
this they were you know extolling the
virtues of data analytics for business
intelligence and they were putting up
plots that look just like this one so
here I want to emphasize
is that the causal state doesn't have to
be a binary variable policy or not
policy it could actually be a continuous
variable as well so here we have the
number of words in the headline of an
article versus the click-through rate
for the article or the number of times
or the sorry the proportion of times
when the article is shown that it gets
clicked on so the question the authors
were looking at and I'm not citing the
the blog post intentionally because I
don't like to to point out people
specifically for this kind of behavior
is what they're looking at is what's the
optimal number of words and a title and
from this plot you might infer that it's
somewhere around 16 to 18 words in the
title gives you the peak in the the
click-through rate but the problem here
is they're assuming a certain model of
the world where the headline length
directly affects the the click-through
rate but there are nor ignoring common
causes between the two so just to kind
of think of some and it's pretty pretty
easy to think of things as an exercise
in these different contexts so just to
think of one you might think may be a
very good author prefers certain length
headlines but also because they're a
very good author they also write very
click clicky headlines so it's headlines
that people will want to click on so
people view their articles a lot more so
just who the author is could confound
the headline length and the the
click-through rate so maybe we just have
one author who's particularly successful
who also prefers 16 to 18 word headlines
so that's that's one example of a
confounder that could cause the the
relationship you're seeing there where
there's this spike at 16 to 18 words so
generally the world is complicated there
are lots of different causes of any
particular variable you care about when
you're when you're making a policy
intervention it's a little bit less
because you have control over for
example the the headline length if you
were able to control it then you could
do something like an experiment or an
a/b test but generally if you have
observational data you don't have that
luxury and you kind of have to worry
about everything else in the world
driving extra correlation between
variables that you care about so this is
why we run experiments and this is the
generality of this problem is is
something that makes it something you
have to worry about in general when
you're in an observational context let
me just yep cool any any questions so
far it's probably another good pausing
point yep that's right that's right yeah
so if the key to narrowing it down is
we're talking about causes of the causal
state and causes of the outcome so that
gives you a kind of foothold to start
looking at what variables do I actually
care about for this so that's that's one
way to start narrowing it down cool so
so when when generally should you care
about this so there are really two
sources of bias if you kind of break
down the world so we argued that there's
bias due to this spurious relationship
introduced by common causes and that
bias actually falls into two categories
and only two categories you can actually
show this with with some algebra so the
first type of a thing I'll just explain
with an example and then kind of show
the the more theoretical version is what
if people who get the treatment or see
the ad we're already more likely to
click on it so that's or we're already
more likely to purchase the product so
that's that's something that might
happen if if if the user is very active
so the people who are seeing the ad
because they're active online are also
more likely to click the product there's
a second type of bias that can happen
which is the people who are more likely
to see the ad for the product we're also
the people who the ad is more effective
on so it's a difference in the effect of
seeing the advertisement so there's if
you wanted to kind of abstract that a
little bit to think about it across
different contexts what we're really
talking about is there's a baseline
difference in the outcome so the people
who saw the advertisement we're more
likely to buy the product
or not they saw the advertisement and
then there's a difference in the effect
of the treatment so the the
effectiveness of the ad in this context
you can think of this also in a medical
context with the effective of medicine
so just - yep so this this stuff matters
in general when these two things are
possible
so this is a way to think about it in a
different context than with common
causes but instead in in the context of
potential outcomes cool any any
questions on that before I move on okay
great so that brings us to the question
okay we care about this the biases can
be large if we don't do something about
it
so how do you actually do something
about it
just to kind of make a precise point on
the size of the bias if you're talking
about a binary policy outcome you really
just care if the the causal effect is
positive or negative so really you just
care if implementing the policy would
have a positive effect or whether it
would have a negative effect and so the
question there is how much bias can you
tolerate and still get the correct sign
and the answer is 100% bias so you can
get anything less than 100% bias and the
sign doesn't flip so if you can find a
causal inference method that gives you
better than 100% bias then you're in
good shape
cool okay so how do you actually do this
type of bias adjustment so let's look at
what an experiment actually does and
that'll give us some intuition for four
methods that we can use to correct for
bias so what an experiment does is it
takes this observational system on the
left here where we have no control over
who sees the advertisement just because
it's running on the site and in an
uncontrolled way and it says we're
actually gonna control whether or not
people see the advertisement so we'll
decide beforehand that if if some people
with odd numbered user IDs come to the
site they get to see the advertisement
if it's even numbered they don't user
IDs are randomly assigned so that gives
us random assignment so we'll just kind
of take this very simple type of
experiment and what that does is it
removes Z as a cause for the causal
date so it's no longer driven by user
activity they would see it if they're
active enough and not otherwise and so
we've got this type of control over the
system and so we've we've got D
independent of Z so let's let's get a
little bit more rigorous about this so
we can kind of build this up a little
bit more precisely and that's going to
lead it lead us to some quantitative
methods we can use to do this kind of
bias removal so we have our binary
causal state and this is what our our
data matrix looks like we have our
outcome variable Y over here so these
might be a number of pageviews during a
week or something similar and then we
have these two other variables which
I'll define now so these two other
variables are called potential outcome
variables y1 is the outcome that would
happen if the person had been assigned
to the D equals to 1 state and y0 is the
outcome that would be if the person was
assigned to the D equals to 0 state so
you can see you only measure one of
these at a time because the person can
only be in one state and so that that
actually presents a specific problem
what that what that's what that says is
we can never actually measure a
difference between y 1 and y 0 for any
individual and so we can never actually
see the causal effect that we care about
which is the difference in the outcome
from one state to the other so this is a
problem both in experiments and in and
in observational settings so what we end
up doing is say let's let's use the
expectation here this is expected
difference and let's use the linearity
of that to say it's actually the
expected difference in y1 and the
expected difference in y0 and let's see
if we can actually get somewhere with
that so we don't measure y1 and y 0
directly instead we just measure the
outcome Y and it happens to be y1 if D
equals to 1 and it's y 0 when D equals
to zero so what we've actually measured
isn't the expected value isn't y1 over
all units which would let us get that
average at the top there or y0 over all
units which would let us get the average
on the right-hand side but what we've
got is just Y given D equals to 1 and
given D equals to zero so what we need
to do to actually get this average at
the top that we care about is look at
the I'm sorry is make this assumption
that y 1 and y 0 are independent of D
which makes us free to condition on DS
that is free to look at subsets of the
population so what we assume then is
that people in the y equals sorry D
equals to 1 state for whom we measure y
1 a representative of the whole
populations Y 1 values so an average
within the the treatment group is the
same average we would measure if the
control units had been in the the
treatment group so that's the assumption
that we're making and because of
randomization that is random assignment
we make sure D is actually independence
of everything and so we do get this
independence of D from the potential
outcome variables are there any
questions here at this point this is
kind of the the the core problem in
causal inference yeah this problem of
not being able to observe y 1 and y 0
simultaneously is called the fundamental
problem with causal inference and this
is the the solution to it it's it's this
assumption of under none confounded miss
go any questions ok great
so in an observational study we
generally don't have that type of
independence so we can actually look for
something a little bit weaker called
conditional independence so it's not
that y 1 and y 0 are independent of D
it's that they're independent of D
within some specific context so in the
case of this user activity example we
can say okay what if what if we we don't
assume that D and Z are independent of
each other or that y&z are independent
of each other what if instead we assume
that if you fix a Z you remove this the
spurious dependence so remember the D D
is is more likely so people are more
likely to see the ad when Z is higher so
the person is more active they're more
likely to buy the product when the
person is more active and that variation
in these variables is what drives this
spurious relationship or this this
biostat effect
so what you could have instead is say
let's fix the value of Z so only look at
a subpopulation with one specific value
of Z so we remove that source of the
covariation between D and Y and within
that population we have an unbiased
effect so that's that's kind of the core
of the trick here that's this is called
conditional independence so y 1 and y 0
are independent to D conditional on Z or
that is within subpopulations where Z is
held constant so let's look at a trick
we can we can do to make this work
so let's first generate some data for a
simulated a/b test so what we've got is
we'll have d BR D right here B our
treatment assignment so it's going to be
1 or 0 with a 50/50 probability and then
Y is the outcome so it's a random normal
plus our effect size Delta if they're in
the D equals to 1 state but this term is
0 if they're in the D equals to 0 state
so what we have is people in people in
the D equals 0 state just get a random
normal variable so the average is 0 if
they're in the D equals 1 state they get
a random normal plus +1 or sorry plus
0.5 so the average is is 0.5 for those
outcomes so we can actually estimate
that with the regression and so if we
just use D being binary and find the
average value of y at D then we get this
coefficient on D which if you look at
the confidence intervals agrees with our
causal effect of 0.5 so we have our
regression estimator for the the causal
effect notice the R squared doesn't have
to be good for this to work the better
your r-squared is the more precisely
you're going to end up estimating D so
it makes sense to add extra covariance
if you can account for some of the noise
but you don't have to so why exactly did
this work if you look at our regression
specification it was Delta x so some
coefficient times D and that's that's
that's what our model for Y is plus some
noise term so if you take the the value
you
for Delta that should be the average of
the causal effect and if you actually
look at the data generating process you
can see that right here so taking the
difference between these you just find
Delta as the result cool so let's add a
common cause between D and Y so it's
going to be a very similar data
generating process but we're gonna end
up adding this extra bias to it so we'll
add Z as our common cause so this could
be the user is very active or the user
was online today so some proxy for
activity we have D is a again binomial
variable but this time the probability
depends on Z so it's gonna be point
seven five if the person is active so
much more likely or point five of the
person is not very active we need that
to be a common cause with Y so Y also
has to depend on Z so we're gonna make
it dependent on Z in this kind of funny
way so we're gonna have the the
advertisement be more effective if the
user is is more active so that's our
model for it where the coefficient on
Delta is this Z dependent a piece here
cool so let's let's see what effect this
has if we just kind of do the regression
as we did before so if we look at the
average if we look at the actual causal
effect I've set this up in kind of a
funny way but it turns out that the
coefficient on D is actually the same
value as it was before so we still have
the same causal effect 0.5 which is what
we're looking for but if we run this
regression now we have this bias so bias
so a regression estimates this 0.7
effect width which is statistically
significantly different from the 0.5
effects if you look at the confidence
intervals cool so the solution I
mentioned before where you just kind of
hold Z fixed is the approach that we're
going to take here so let's let's hold Z
fixed so we're gonna switch the data
frame to Z equals to 1 units only
and then regress only on those people so
what we find here is still the
the effect we're looking for but from
the arguments we made earlier this
should be the effect within a
subpopulation right so this is the
effect within those equals to one
subpopulation and hopefully we can use
this to recover the the average causal
effect so then if we go to the Z equals
to zero group we find an effect of minus
0.5 so this this is the wrong sign from
what we had before but maybe we can use
these two together now that we've
measured the causal effect in every sub
population to get the causal effect
averaged over the whole population so as
you might guess the solution is to take
a weighted average between the effects
so if we take the 1.5 we found earlier
and the minus 0.5 we found and average
them together we end up with 0.5 which
is the correct answer so there's an
interesting consequence of this this
analysis which is that this is a
positive positive average effect which
is which is great so this might say we
should probably implement this policy
but you also have to care about the fact
that within a sub population you had a
negative effect so if you're talking
about making a change to a website then
you're actually gonna you're gonna hurt
the experience of about half of the
population if you were to implement this
even though it's a positive change
overall so that's worth worth noticing
cool any any questions at this point
am i doing on time perfect so okay so
this worked because we knew what to
control for we didn't have to control
for too many variables so we could
actually split them up into two
different groups if it were a thousand
groups we wouldn't have enough data
points to do that kind of splitting we
had enough data to to stratify and
perform two separate regressions so this
is not a statistically efficient
approach because we're using two
separate models each fit on some subset
of the data and there there are better
ways that you can tackle the problem but
this is a good one just to illustrate
that this kind of stratification works
other there are a ton of other
approaches and there's a huge literature
on this subject a good book for this is
Morgan win chips counterfactuals and
causal inference that's a very applied
book mostly harmless econometrics is a
great one it's a little bit denser but
it's it covers the methods well and the
other approaches are better in different
contexts if you have a lot more
variables if you don't have a lot of
data if you have unknown variables that
you need to control for then there are
other methods that work well well so
that's this is kind of just a list of
things that you can google later if
you'd like to to find things if I find
other approaches that can work but kind
of the the key takeaway here is if you
really want to do this well there's a
ton of stuff you need to know how to do
and every approach has different caveats
and the caveats aren't something that
you can just know from from looking at
the data
unfortunately so you really actually
have to understand the system well
enough to know whether each method is
justified which means you actually need
to understand the methods really well to
know whether it's assumptions are
satisfied so what that means is there's
a significant learning overhead so
actually picking up these methods and
being able to use them effectively which
is which is a problem if you're looking
at kind of a practical analytics context
which is how do you even hire the people
who can do this stuff so that's that's
it's not as not an insignificant problem
so part of the solution to that I
started writing a package called
causality so you can play with this in
PI
the goal there is to make causal
inference easy so that you don't have to
have as deep a knowledge of it to do it
correctly and to do it safely and by
safely I mean making sure the
assumptions for the the different
algorithms are satisfied so here's a
quick example I'll just run through this
is the propensity score matching method
it's another conditioning based method
that doesn't require stratifying the
data explicitly so here we'll have three
different confounding variables which
are causing D the the causal state and
there's the outcome which is also
dependent on these confounding variables
so we can just drop all this into a data
frame X here at the bottom if you look
at the naive effect just the difference
between the observe a tional treatment
and observational control groups what
you find is a point three six effect if
you compare it with the true effect just
by differencing the potential outcomes
which we know because we we generated
the data ourselves you find the true
effect is actually zero cool so if you
just drop this data into the propensity
score matching you tell it which is the
causal state D which is the outcome Y
and which are the covariance Z and
whether they're continuous or discrete
so it knows how to how to handle them
it'll give you the correct average
treatment effect so it just makes it
pretty quick and easy so it sort of just
works trademark if if you're smart
though you won't stop there because
there are assumptions that the the
algorithm has to satisfy rather the the
system has to satisfy those assumptions
in the context of propensity score
matching and this is actually true in a
lot of different contexts is that the
the Z variables have to have the same
domain for each causal state so when the
D equals to zero state the Z variables
have to have the same domain and
likewise for the the D equals to 1 state
cool so you can actually check that
there are a couple of methods for doing
that just to put that assumption
explicitly it's that this probability
has to be positive for all values of the
inputs
and you can just kind of drop some plots
out to check that visually at least in
1d so there's this check support method
that just generates these plots for you
you can also see how well you did at
balancing on the Z's which is another
kind of technical point of propensity
score matching so there's the kind of is
it worth it question because the biases
are so big you really need to do this if
you're working with observational data
but the time investment makes it
difficult so my argument is if we
develop the right tool set that does
automated assumption checking then it
should be low enough investment and
require low enough expertise that it
should be practical in in a realistic
context just to show one more example
here's an addition to the pandas
dataframe object called Z plot so
instead of just plotting you say Z plot
it takes exactly the same methods and
it'll give you a causal plot instead of
a a correlative plot so if you look at
the causal plot here for the same data
it reverses sine versus the regular old
plot method so this is called Simpsons
paradox where you get this sign reversal
between the different policies so you
can do this as easily as your normal
exploratory data analysis workflow so
this should you should kind of fit
seamlessly into the the usual data
scientist or analyst toolkit cool so
just kind of the last slide where we're
hiring for my team at Barclays so if
you'd like to join join me at work and
learn some of this stuff in in the real
world then just let me know if my email
is right there you could also search for
the job posting online cool I think
that's the that's it so thanks
you
[Music]